everybody oh yeah you'd think growing up
about an hour away from here by that
cruller as a crow flies in Russian New
York I would remember that it's cold
during March but I didn't bring any
sweaters with me
so they've been note for the speaker kit
next joking I shouldn't I should have
known better for sure but it's cold out
there guys noticed oh yeah
thank you honoree I appreciate the intro
I will get into I mean this whole talk
is actually predicated a lot on that
blog post that honoree was mentioning so
what I'd like to talk to you about is
something that I like to refer to as
hyper lightweight websites or hyper
light websites to get it to fit on this
slide so my story at YouTube I was a web
developer I was a second full-time web
developer at YouTube back in 2007 they
had a actually a very sophisticated
engineering team but not that many web
developers obviously my boss who was the
first full-time web developer at YouTube
started three weeks before me so we did
not have that much when we first started
out there wasn't a whole lot of web
sophistication there so we got to have
the unique opportunity to do a lot of
that work for Google at the time and it
all started with this one conversation
so at YouTube we would have these these
architects who would sit down and like
the cafes and have these sort of debates
with people and one of the architects
said this he said if they if they can
build an entire quake clone in less than
100 kilobytes
well I can't we get YouTube the load in
under 1 megabyte I was like oh man that
sounds awesome like we how do you do
that like YouTube at the time was
weighing in at like 5 megabytes and and
that's just to get the video to load
right that's all the JavaScript all the
image content the thumbnails all that
stuff so that became my challenge I was
like oh man I'm gonna do this I don't
know if you guys know much about the bay
area but Google is about 20 miles south
of San Francisco and I live in San
Francisco and so there's a an hour long
bus ride you take every day to get down
there and back
right so this is my time to work on this
project it was on the bus and what came
of it was this project called YouTube
feather YouTube feather was a Hyperlight
version of YouTube it was designed to
serve the video as fast as possible with
no other constraints particularly we
wanted to maintain about 80% of the user
experience so I got to throw away a lot
of stuff you know I could look at
different pieces of like advertising and
just say we're not going to do that
we're gonna use the latest technologies
so we weren't gonna presume that we're
gonna serve all like 99.5 percent of the
users on the Internet we were just going
to serve the people with the modern
technologies which at the time was
basically iPhones the first Android
devices and you know internet browsers
like the iPad came out in 2010 so even
that was too new and then go one of the
goals was to make as few requests as
possible and so one of the results or
the the results are actually pretty
astounding it was 98 kilobytes for
everything but the video when I got it
all baked down into its base components
we were able to do it in 14 total
requests from three domains and it was
also my first opportunity to pull in my
other side project which was the html5
video player so I got to work on that
project as well so basically building
the html5 video spec was coming out at
the time we got to work on that as well
it was based on CSS JavaScript and HTML
html5 so I got to plug that in and
that's what actually got us under that
hurdle of 1 megabyte and speaking to
that blog post it opened up new regions
of the world which is one of the most
interesting things that came out of this
project we were able to reach
sub-saharan Africa rural parts of India
and rural parts of China parts of South
America that we couldn't reach before
because it would take 20 minutes to load
the page and that was taking two minutes
which seems insane when you're in
Toronto and you have amazing you know
Internet connectivity but in those parts
of the world it's very very slow and
very very inconsistent
the internet maybe up and maybe down
there might be power there might not be
power so this was actually really
interesting and it actually threw us for
a loop we couldn't really we didn't
really know why when we rolled this out
or hagrid aggregate latency numbers
actually went up and the reason it went
up when we looked at the geo the
geography of it all was that people were
using YouTube for the first time so
instead of them not using YouTube now
they're using YouTube and they were
dragging our numbers in the wrong
direction but it was actually a positive
so that's like an important thing to
remember like we're not all in you know
metropolis is with great Wi-Fi and great
internet but in fact we still have high
latency environments everywhere even to
this day like the thing that scares me
to death
is this gogo internet or if airplane
Wi-Fi I'm sure you guys have experienced
this at one point or another but it's
pretty awful right like it's terrible
and every web site you try to load is
gonna be pretty slow and it's
inconsistent it drops in and out you
know you hit some cloud cover it's
actually the perfect metaphor for the
rest of the world so try out your
website on gogo in-flight Wi-Fi and and
see how it goes so as part of this so
feather was sort of the first time I
creator built this process or worked
through this process of designing a
Hyperlight website and it's something
that I've done many many times over and
over and my hope today is to kind of
show you some of that process and
something you can adapt to your own
needs and whatnot but what it
fundamentally is is it is a rican
ception of a web-based user interface
designed purely for performance like
that you get to throw away every other
constraint every other thing you're
thinking about for the most part just a
focus on performance and that will give
you a baseline to evaluate the rest of
your website against right like there is
no such thing as zero latency right so
it's always going to be some latency
there's always going to be some cost to
delivering your website and you want to
find that lowest cost possible so you
can measure against it and try to find
the pieces that are costing you the most
and so that's I'm gonna walk us through
today in this presentation and so the
metaphor that I like to use and there's
a car theme to this for no other reason
that at the time I was shopping for a
car but we're trying to build a Formula
One car
right we are trying to build a race car
you can't drive that thing to the mall
you can't pick your kids up in it you
you cannot actually drive that on the
street
you need special gravel and you need
special tires and you need all these
special things but it does allow you to
push the limits of performance right
these are the fastest cars out there and
that's the metaphor right and so you
need to understand that this is not
meant to become your website this is
what you're using to kind of measure
what's possible with your website and
then try to dial it back and figure out
how to get yourself somewhere in between
these right let's walk through the steps
to doing this all those steps that I do
to do this well here it is the goal as
fast as possible just discuss this but
it's you want to get as roughly
consistent with the real thing as
possible so you want it to look and feel
just like your website would otherwise
look and feel but you want to be
perceptually indistinguishable but it
may be very distinguishable under the
hood not to use it but so the first
thing you want to do is identify the
most active page on your website so at
YouTube for instance I don't think most
people would know this because you
probably picture as this giant you know
he myth of a website but there's really
only two pages on YouTube there's the
search page in the watch page so the
video view page is what we call the
watch page and so those are the two
pages you should focus on and in fact
the search page is actually pretty
pretty fast already right so the one
that we focused on was the watch page
and it's very likely that if you are
running like a prototypical website
probably only have a few pages that are
just used a lot right so if you're an
e-commerce website you have a product
page and a search results page if you're
a blog you know a blog site you probably
have a feed page and a blog post page
right so find the one that is the most
actively used it's a blog post it's
probably the blog post
if it's an e-commerce site is probably
the product page and you're gonna you're
gonna select that one you're gonna build
a new version from scratch that is this
hyper light version so you're gonna
you're gonna take it down to the studs
you're not going to reuse any of your
infrastructure for the most part you're
just going to build it up from the
ground up and you're going to basically
you're gonna you're gonna work from HTML
to CSS to JavaScript
all right so try to do all as much as
you can in HTML then do as much as you
can in CSS and as much as you can in
JavaScript assemble it all into one
hyper light HTML page we'll talk about
some of the techniques for doing that
shortly put it behind a simple CDN you
know you can do cloud front or fastly or
CloudFlare or any of these try to get it
behind a CDN so you can see you know
things like a compression and pipelining
work for you I don't recommend for this
kind of a project to try to spin up your
own HTTP to pipelining it's a lot of
work let the pros do it and then you're
gonna measure both that page uncashed
and the hyper lightweight page uncashed
as well see how fast they load and then
analyze results and that's the big part
here is that you want to build a model
that you can analyze against there's a
couple of things that you should do you
should keep in your hyper light version
your baseline you should keep real
content
so no lorem ipsum doler content no no
fake content try to use the the physical
content like coming from an API because
that's how you're going to load the
content no matter what you do so if
you're using you know each XML HTTP
requests xhr stuff you should pull that
stuff in as you would otherwise you
should keep responsive layouts so if
you're serving to an iPad or iPhone you
should make sure you provide some
affordance to those devices as you would
otherwise because these are really use
cases right everybody looks at the web
on their phone for the most part these
days so make sure you're supporting that
to some degree doesn't have to be
perfect doesn't have to be completely
change around your whole UI
it could literally just be things rink
effectively just so that you can
maintain that user interface and the
smallest amount of code in some cases
you should do things like spriting to
cut down on the number of image requests
that you're making and I'll talk about
that in great detail a little bit later
SVG I'm a huge fan of SVG whenever you
can use SVG it compresses really well
especially if you sprite it we'll talk
about that a little bit so it's very
important if you can if you can do SVG
for non photographic assets you SVG it's
significant it cuts down on on latency
cost tremendously and then accessibility
we have to make sure we pay attention to
accessibility it has to be included in
there you have to make sure that your UI
functions for everybody because that's
you know critical for serving your user
base so if you know your user base and a
user base is the wider Internet make
sure you're putting in affordances for
accessibility now we can talk about the
things we get to throw out so this is
something that I like to do just because
now keep in mind this is just for the
purposes of this baseline because this
allows you to understand what things are
gonna cost you later because there are
trade-offs we're talking about here
right if you're running a business that
is like ad driven you have to have ads
so that's just a reality it's a
financial reality it's a matter of
physics so in this case we just want to
know what those ads cost us because
they're costing us more in sort of
page-load and and you know download
times and it's costing us users that
cost may exceed the value of the ads are
providing to begin with so you have to
make sure you're paying attention you
know to that as well and the way to do
that is to actually cut out the ads for
the space line and then look at how much
they actually cost you later CMS
integration so this is again a similar
thing if your business is like provide
if you're providing a content media you
know you're a guardian or your New York
Times there might be some value in
having a CMS integration that allows
your editorial staff to edit the article
content that you have right and that
usually requires you to have some
embedded codes from JavaScript
we're not going to do that in this
example right but just is not a use case
we need to serve to satisfy because
we're just trying to target the end user
javascript libraries tend to be pretty
heavy and they allow you to do a lot of
nice things we're gonna throw most of
those out as well we basically just need
some simple XML HTTP requests if we want
them otherwise we're gonna try not to
use them the browser's have a lot of
stuff built in as that quote if you can
read it kind of indicates write a lot of
companies now are are going library
lists for some of this stuff CSS layouts
by a frameworks we're gonna use all the
latest and greatest CSS right there's
some really cool stuff out there you may
or may not be aware of a lot of it
there's stuff coming out everyday I'll
leave it to other people to kind of work
through some of those because I have
some of them in here but there's always
new stuff coming out we're gonna not use
the established frameworks a lot of
those frameworks are built at a time
when we didn't have access to these CSS
capabilities and now we do so we're
gonna use the new capabilities and throw
out the frameworks we're also not gonna
be lazy loading of content that is a
complicated process we're going to
instead load all the content in one
payload or as much of it as possible in
one payload and leave the lazy loading
to later ladies loading is an effective
way to cut down on on bandwidth sent
down the wire unless it's needed but a
lot of people take advantage of that a
lot of websites take advantage of that
to just ship more content so we're going
to we're just going to put less content
into our webpage rather than lazy load a
lot of content in so a good example of
this is at YouTube on the watch page we
start with 20 videos in the related
video section and then you can load more
and if you scroll it'll load more in the
feather example I cut that to 5 because
that's all anybody would ever see anyway
so and that just ended up being a
performance benefit just ship 5 related
videos down the wire that's all anybody
needed to see to keep using YouTube for
the most part
data uris so data your eyes are not
inherently compressible they're not very
easily compressed we're gonna try to
avoid them they seem convenient in some
sense that means if you're not aware
what that means it means plugging like
an image into the image source tag
directly via a data URI they are about a
33% hit or increase in length to put
those into the HTML page itself we also
aren't gonna do JavaScript and CSS
compilation again I believe that or
having done this a lot at Google
JavaScript and CSS compilation is a
performance benefit for sure but it also
allows you to put a lot more stuff in
there that you don't actually need so
again we're trying to get rid of stuff
we're trying to just ship as few bytes
as possible to deliver one user
experience so we're gonna cut that out
and then web fonts all the designers in
here will probably hate me for this but
the web fonts just aren't that necessary
a lot of the time and so they are
expensive they're big they don't
compress particularly well because there
are a lot of glyphs if you can isolate
it down to a few characters that's
awesome and I would recommend doing that
but for the purposes of this example
we're just going to use out-of-the-box
fonts so let's take you through this
example whoops so again I was saying I
was in the market for a car and I'm not
a big car person per se but just I was
in the market for a car and I was
curious about like how what the modern
web looks like so I was looking at a
company at a site called car and driver
magazine and apologies I should have
slowed that up a little bit
and I was just curious like what is it
what does it weigh in and I mean this is
a this is a pretty cool website I was
looking at it on a plane so I kind of
felt some of the performance headaches
but I was like oh this looks like a
clean modern web site what's under the
hood so this is what we have 101 181
requests from 50 domains and the total
content size is 8.7 megabytes and this
is what their website used to be like
they've done some updates so I will talk
about that in a minute but it would take
five point nine megabytes just to get
that first page hit to load now that's
not a lot if you're talking about using
cable modems
you know fiber-optic cabling and all
that kind of stuff but it is a lot when
you're on gogo in-flight Wi-Fi and non
image content was 2 Meg's that's huge
like normally you think a website like
this would be predominantly image
content but a third of it is is just a
non image content so stuff that's like
HTML Javascript CSS is 2 Meg's and
that's after that's compressed right
that's pretty insane image content 4
megabytes and then this is a number that
I always pay attention to is like what
are you actually paying for right so CDN
a content delivery network it's it's
what you're usually paying for if you're
one of these web sites so of all that
content the first party content 5 5
megabytes per page load it's a lot it
can add up very quickly and now here's
the most interesting thing is the
response times right so I time this out
2g is 22 seconds just to get it to start
showing up and almost 3 minutes to get
the whole page to load on a legacy 2g
website or app platform 3G six point
four seconds 53 to 53 to load the whole
page and then a high-speed modem it's
1.5 seconds to 16 seconds so you can see
the disparity here right if you are in
sub-saharan Africa not sure why you'd be
on Car and Driver calm but like 22
seconds just to get it to start doing
anything that's a long time right and
then get it three minutes just to get
that page to load now you want to look
at a an article on the page it's gonna
take you another three minutes you
abandon immediately right so it's not
good so I built a hyper lightweight
version this is the hyper lightweight
version and here's the original so you
can see there's some subtle differences
the web fonts behind me being the most
there's some some subtle shifts in some
of the spacing that's just more me
missing some of the calculations a
little bit but you can tell this is
basically the same web page for the end
user sans ads
right so like what is this what does
this end up being so I got it down to 32
requests in two domains that's a pretty
big improvement 1.1 megabytes of total
content so that's an 87 4 or 87 percent
decrease in content and only 1 Meg's
built by the CDN so your cost improve so
that's really cool now here's the most
interesting thing the performance on a
2g goes to 773 milliseconds to get it to
start loading something so that's
realistic right it's like pretty fast
425 milliseconds so less than a second
to load in in every environment that's
up there that's a huge improvement and
only 11 seconds so if you look at the 2g
it's 11 seconds to get it to fully load
whereas would take 22 seconds to just
get it to start painting anything in the
previous mode right or any in the
original mode and I by no means I'm
taking any credit for this but sometime
the last month or so they launched a new
version or they made a bunch of these
changes to actually improve their
performance so I figured let's measure
that and talk about it
so they made some improvements this is a
new website image front and center yeah
it's pretty aggressive truck right there
[Music]
so let's see how they're improved
stacked up so they did some interesting
things they actually increased the
number of requests and domains I haven't
really spent enough time analyzing that
to figure out where they're all going
but I imagine they're going to marketing
trackers and add platforms and all that
fun stuff but they did get some
improvements they actually cut the
amount of total content I can tell you
for a fact they weren't gzip compressing
before and I think they are now so we'll
talk about this in a minute but gzip
compression is actually pretty important
for HTML and JavaScript and CSS that's
just a it's a layup they should have
been doing that if they weren't already
doing it their total transfer went down
by more than half
or actually about
equal almost yeah more than half their
images stayed about the same
that's okay I mean they actually put a
bunch of more images on the web website
so works out to be a net positive
actually I'm sorry they're non images
they put a lot more of it but they
actually have their image content they
did decrease to match more what I was
doing so they they did increase the
number of images but they did apply some
better compression and other techniques
to get those images to load about equal
to what I was doing and the hyper light
stuff and of course they cut their their
bill their build amount and you can see
here their actual increase in
performance so they cut their 2g
performance by about between a third and
a half or a mr. I should say it's down
to about a third or a half depending on
if you're looking at paint or
fully-loaded and their and their actual
performance on the the high end is much
much better so it's six hundred twenty
milliseconds to ten seconds still pretty
bad there's a lot they could do but
again they're running a business I'm
giving a talk like there's a very big
difference here between what our
motivations are so let's talk about some
of the techniques that go into building
a Hyperlight website our techniques that
you should apply to your website if you
want to get lighter content so the first
one that I like to talk about a lot is
inline as much as you possibly can if
you've worked with these like
server-side frameworks I personally like
a technology called tornado this is
tornado you know you can use whatever
there's all sorts of rails and Python
and all that kind of stuff that you can
apply node and so but the key thing here
is inlining instead of linking can't do
that it's not it's not valuable to do
that across you know your entire website
most of the time it's better to have an
external file that you load once and
then link into a bunch of different
pages but for the purposes of this we
want to get that down to one resource as
much as possible or get most of our UI
content or non-image content into one
resource so we're gonna inline it
that's what we're doing here so we're
just basically taking our stylesheet and
dumping it straight into the page
creates a bigger page but it ends up
compressing really nicely so you can see
here that's the inline statement this
one's kind of obvious these days but if
you aren't using html5 semantic elements
you should be they have a lot of you
know UI components and things in
intrinsic to them that help you get to a
better user experience faster ninety
five percent of users have access to
these elements so you should be using
them it's pretty straightforward
now we're getting into some more
interesting things so if you aren't
aware about root em sizing will help you
get to a relative layout so people have
to hit zoom in zoom out you should you
you know this would actually allow them
to risa resize your website responsively
if you measure everything relative to
the root m size and what that is is the
font size at the root so HTML has a font
size set to I like 16 because it divides
really well and then you measure
everything off that initial font size so
whenever somebody hits you know command
+ or command - to do the zoom zoom in
zoom out your website should respond
responsively just intrinsically so it's
an easy way to get sort of free
responsiveness in your website without
having to do breakpoints and all that
stuff right out of the box ninety-six
percent of users support that the next
one is probably the one that I am the
most excited about it's not that new but
it is pretty new and if you're not using
it you should be CSS grids like CSS
grids can cut down on the amount of HTML
you have significantly they also make
your UI so much more responsive 87% of
users have access to CSS grids currently
and by far this is the probably the
number one thing that I did in this
particular example to decrease page
weight just using CSS grids prior to
that there was the Flex box similar
effect you should use you should use
either of these technologies which are
very more comfortable with but I highly
recommend looking into CSS grids and
there's a link at the bottom to Google
material i/o which you can use to kind
of learn more about grids if you don't
know about them already
this one is I was kind of surprised is
as supporters as it is HTML templating
so building templates into your header
or into the head tag of your HTML so
that you can copy that using some
JavaScript and then duplicate it into
your page on page load it's actually
quite fast this is the code to do it so
in this case if we were loading in a
bunch of articles we could actually in
line or xhr some javascript documents
json documents into the page and just
map them into templates on the client
it's a pretty effective way to get a lot
of content like article content or list
content to render into your page without
having to use a ton of javascript 89% of
users support HTML templates now this
one is a little bit interesting so a
friend of mine taught me or showed me
this and it's very clever you can use
the targeting the target selector from
CSS which is the little hash mark that
goes into the URL whenever you change
states on the page to actually affect UI
and content on the page so you can
actually get things to show like search
boxes and stuff like that or or
different page transitions to show up by
using the target selector and CSS now
there's a caveat to that at the moment
the fragment identifier which is that
little hash mark that gets set in your
your browser URL will get added to your
browser history so you only want to do
this if it's a significant page
transition that you're doing without
changing the actual you know pay or the
actual HTML request so this is useful if
you're like looking at products and you
want the person will navigate through a
bunch of products you have those
products load it into a single page web
app and you want them to be able to go
back and forward over those products but
it is not particularly useful if they're
just showing and hiding a search box
which is the example itest you sortition
have used but 96% of customer of your
users support this now so definitely
think about that it does make hiding and
showing UI especially if it's
significant you eye
much simpler replacing SVG with HTML and
CSS this was a big win in this
particular example so this is a piece of
UI which is the paging UI for the main
article content and I was able to
replace it using SVG HTML and CSS it was
a bunch of images before and they
weren't even spreaded together so those
images were about five kilobytes and now
they're one kilobyte and then they're
probably even smaller because those SVG
elements are actually compiled into an
SVG sprite sheet which is I think the
next item we'll talk about and that
actually makes it even smaller
ninety-three percent of users have
access to SVG in spriting I'm sorry SVG
so this is SVG spriting so what we're
doing here is we're creating one SVG
element with all of our icons all of our
graphics inside of it and then we're
referencing pieces of it throughout our
web page so if you're not aware of what
spriting is it's it actually originates
in like gaming computer games like Mario
you have this big block of memory that
contains all of your image resources or
image data and you just kind of create a
little window over top of it and just
pick out that piece of it to show on the
screen right so you get to have one
block of visual media information that
you select pieces and chunks out of and
it means that in the web world you only
have one resource that you're operating
on which is very very which cuts down
the number of requests cuts on number of
loads that you have to do and
decompresses event like say an image so
it's very very useful so I highly
recommend doing this in fact this is
again that like between HTML templating
and this I think these are the two
biggest wins that was able to find 91%
of users support this
so this brings us to another topic which
is the image based spriting image based
spriting is when you take a bunch of
images and you combine them into one
single image now this isn't particularly
new this is actually something a lot of
companies will be doing for a very long
time you look at the Google logo on
Google search I think it's still a
sprite you see all their little icons
low it load up again it allows you to
compress everything into a single
response compress it all together into
one response the the issue here is that
we actually HTTP to pipelining is
actually probably the more modern better
way to do this so if you're unaware hvp
2 has this concept of pipelining where
once you establish a connection to a
particular host you can send multiple
resources down the wire because
historically an HTTP 1 if you're loading
say 10 images each time you load an
image you have to negotiate with that
host to basically load the image or to
get it to deliver the image to you and
you can actually short-circuit that
using HTTP 2 pipelining so image
spriting is not as useful as it once was
if you support HTTP 2 pipelining however
if you are doing a bunch of mobile
application development loading a single
image is usually better than loading 10
images so spreading them still has that
value even if it is HT HTTP pipelining
the reason is the way that images are
loaded into memory on the mobile devices
so facebook is invented or created a
bunch of libraries to help you do this
kind of stuff to to avoid the costs of
having to load and switch context in the
devices like GPU and stuff like that 96%
of users support this now one that's
near and dear to my heart
responsive images using sources so as
onry mentioned I'm the CEO of a company
called image X we do image processing as
a service specifically to solve this
particular problem which is having a
high resolution image asset that you
want to serve in a mall
of dimensions to your customers and you
want those to be responsive so you want
them to be able to be delivered to the
device as the device is indicating that
it wants that image delivered so
historically speaking we would create
ten different sizes of an image say
you're an e-commerce website and you
have a product photo of some shoes and
you want to show those shoes on in a
multitude of ways you want to like
create a thumbnail you want a product
shot you would actually just create
those ten images in Photoshop and save
them to a bucket somewhere unfortunately
nowadays we have so many devices you can
no longer predict where why and how
those images are going to be used so the
better way to do this is to store one
high resolution master asset and then
use a service like image X to compact to
resize scale crop manipulate that image
based on the request from the browser
request from the user and one of the
ways you can do this is in this example
you can see we have in this case our our
particular host name which will make
images let me back up for a second the
way that we work is we will connect to
your existing bucket say an s3 bucket
you've loaded your images your
high-resolution master images into an s3
bucket you tell us how to connect to
that bucket we give you a hostname back
like this one this is car and driver CND
meaning Car and Driver dot image X net
which will link directly to your images
so if you want to get to a Honda JPEG it
would go right it would connect directly
to your s3 bucket pull the Honda that
JPEG and serve it through us right all
through a CDN as well now the cool thing
is you can add these parameters like in
this case we're going to set that with
to 200 we're going to change the format
to a progressive jpg highly recommended
we're going to support Auto formatting
which means it will actually negotiate
with say Chrome and deliver a web P if
web P is available and then it'll also
do some compression that we drive so
they use some perceptual compression
things like that automatically that's
just off your original master image
which is usually megabytes and megabytes
we turn it into the kilobytes that you
want and because it's responsive we can
actually put this into the hole source
set and do things like change the DPR of
the image
so that you can now serve multiple DPRs
multiple image sizes all too you know
without having to store multiple
versions of that image so this is
actually very useful because it enables
you to serve the least amount of image
bytes to your users as necessary and
that's not just it's not just a plug
it's just literally like how you get
faster like if you look at the image
content if you looked at the image
content sizes before it was the most
notable shift in our decrease in page
weight focus on the images and 88% of
responsive images or 88% of browsers
support source set so you should use it
the gzip compression so this we're
starting to get into there's only about
two or three more of these that I can
recommend at the moment but this is a
big one
gzip compression if you're not doing
this I know that a lot of web developers
are very front-end focused and not
necessarily back in focus but this is a
critical option you should turn on or
get your DevOps people to turn on
because if you forget to do this it's
very expensive
so what gzip compression does is it it's
an old-school compression algorithm that
takes text and like deduplicate sit and
stores it in a deduplicated form that
you can Unruh verse and get the original
form back if you look at HTML code it's
a million tags that are duplicated over
and over again and this is why things
like SVG are so powerful is because
they're just the same you know values
copied over and over and over again you
have thousands of tags but they're all
the same tag you know or there's like
maybe twenty tags or using so the gzip
compression works really really well on
this kind of content so you should turn
this on at every opportunity that you
can key thing whether it's you or your
devops people make sure you very on
accept-encoding in your caching layers
otherwise you could be sending gzip
content to people who don't support it
which is very rare these days but it's
pretty destructive to their user
experience because they just get a
download they don't actually get your
website
so make sure that happens but once you
do that I mean 99% of users nowadays
support gzip compression it's pretty
cool
in a similar vein Google released
brought Lee brought Lee is a new
compression algorithm you should
experiment with it because I was shocked
I didn't realize that this was as
supported as it is nowadays but if you
can if you have the sophistication to
support bratli and again this is a
server-side thing you should do it
84% sorry 84% of users support bratli
out-of-the-box right now which I was
shocked by I mean it's so new and yet
it's anybody has an Android device can
take advantage of this right now as far
as I understand it so and that gets even
better compression than gzip you want to
get really small use broadly HTTP to
pipelining we've kind of talked a little
bit about this but make sure that as
you're delivering this content
it's HTTP foot - I'm sorry HTTP -
pipelining and what that means is again
we are using there here's here's how you
check make sure it says protocol h2 and
what that does is you can see on this
bar on the right hand side everything
has been pre-negotiated so there's no
hit after that first hit there's no real
hit to the - have to negotiate
everything goes down the same pipe it's
pretty powerful and 84 percent of users
use that or I support that now the whole
point of doing all of this is to be able
to measure the output that we've gotten
right so I showed you the results
already we got a significant amount of
performance benefits from applying these
techniques to car and driver magazine's
website I'm going to show you quickly
one way of measuring it I use site speed
you can also use webpagetest I don't
care what you use it's more about the
activity of actually measuring what
you're doing so this is an example of
just what a site speed report will show
you I used to be just because I can do
it locally and it will actually deliver
you know some basic so actually very
detailed measurements on what's
happening on this webpage like how many
domains are being loaded what a first
party
third party you can slow it up you can
speed it down according to which Network
conditions you want to support yeah so
use one of these tools this is essential
what you want to be able to do is create
a baseline measure it using these tools
measure existing website against it
compare the two reports and make
decisions off of them and so in this
case on Car and Driver magazine and this
still remains the case I found the
biggest part of the website that needs
to be improved it's kind of ridiculous
it's 600 kilobytes to load this basic UI
where you select the car to go drill
down into more article content those are
all individual high-resolution PNG s for
some reason they could benefit
tremendously by spreading them together
and like compressing them properly and
using responsive images that would cut
550 kilobytes out of their web page
right off the gate right out of the gate
and if they did an SVG sprite which I
had our designers do it gets down to
about 15 kilobytes for all that UI so
it's a significant performance savings
that's costing them real money I mean
you got to remember there's like
millions and millions of people hitting
this website every day and their
bandwidth bills are probably you know in
the tens of thousands of dollars a month
so they could cut back tremendously by
just optimizing this one piece of code
so last slide the key thing here is to
make this a process that you run
constantly right building a Hyperlight
web website or web page is is a process
that should take about a day it's not
something you should invest a tremendous
amount of time in you should be able to
do this kind of work very quickly just
to get a baseline again you're throwing
a lot of the concerns out the window you
should be able to do this on other pages
as well if there are important pages to
you but the concept is to build this
into a process to deliver the
measurements that you want to see
compare the measurements and then
evaluate what steps you need to take so
repeat the process repeat it
consistently with the current page at
working on repeat it with other pages
and then one of the things that this is
what LED feather to become
a thing is that we ran a 1% test you
actually put a 1% of our traffic through
it that's what we started to see those
latency numbers change and which is very
valuable to us because that actually
informed the next like 5 years of web
development on how what we were doing
and how we were thinking about it we
created new frameworks we created new
approaches to serving the watch page it
changed a lot of the reasons that we
were doing things away we're doing them
so definitely try to get some traffic in
it I would not recommend putting 100% of
your traffic in it obviously because
it's going to not meet all of your
end-users needs but if you can isolate
your end users in some way and serve 1
percent of them which 1 percent of
YouTube's traffic is a lot of traffic
it's valuable using this information you
should build a performance budget so how
much are you willing to trade for one
thing versus another like I said that
before ads you're serving ads you should
understand exactly how much those ads
are costing you before your to your end
users before actually putting those ads
on your web page and then do this
regularly like constantly be reforming
your your performance budget like Rhian
forming your performance budget so
figure out exactly you know what your
metrics are how they've changed in the
last month or so you can do this with a
tool like site speed or web webpagetest
but if you can even get to a point where
you're constantly re-evaluating those
numbers like automatically you can
really really hone in on what's costing
you the most money and how to save for
your end users so that's basically it I
have some source code up if anybody
wants to see it the live demo I believe
is still up on HLW director Sakurai
Connell verify that but yeah I only have
one minute so I'm probability questions
but I'll be around if anybody wants to
chat or connect I'm here until about 4
o'clock today then I have to fly back
but definitely say hello love to talk to
you so thank you
you